my name is val kilmer i'm an actor i
gotta tell you i'm so excited to talk to
you because i found this movie
about your dad to be so fascinating not
just because we get
a peek into his life but also his brain
like we get a glimpse into that as well
you know and i just kept thinking when i
was watching it this man has lived
so many lives it's difficult to talk and
to be understood
but i want to tell my story more than
ever jack as someone who
literally you know was the voice for
your dad
and narrating this movie um what do you
think was the message he was trying to
get across about his life
i think he wanted people to see
different sides of him that
haven't been seen before in the public
eye and
i think he really had something to say
about life and about
being about creativity and
i'm not quite sure how to articulate
that message
but it it's very clear in the film that
he loves life and he is
he is dedicated to creating being
creative person
and creating art yeah you do you
definitely got that watching
it um you know i love that uh when you
were narrating they did show a couple of
times where you're like wait
did that really happen uh what would you
say was the most surprising thing that
you learned about your dad or story that
you
found out about well i did not know that
doc holliday was a dentist
okay i obviously knew the doc part but i
didn't i thought that was like a cool
nickname
and you know my dad was really uh
dedicated is really dedicated to acting
and he doesn't
really talk about his process that often
maybe that's because he's at a ninja
level of acting
but and also because he's probably
talked about his whole life
right and um but just to see him as a
young man just
learn this craft was just so cool
and mercedes for you watching this film
back was there anything that surprised
you
or made you emotional yeah a lot of them
know the entire movie made me emotional
and i wouldn't say things surprised me
like
about my dad he's such an open person
that i know very well a lot obviously
but
but it did really surprise me to see it
with the audience or to i'm so used to
people like not
understanding my dad i'm so used to his
public image being different than
the like playful funny person that we
know
um so it did kind of really move me
and surprised me to see audiences like
see really see him for the first time
and that was incredible
and yeah to see his life this like
collage of all of his different lives
themselves like to see it narrativize
cohesively to see our lives like kind of
made sense of in this two-hour
narrative was pretty profound obviously
your dad was such a fixture in hollywood
and has had so many iconic roles
but much has been said or written about
him over the years
what would you guys say is the biggest
misconception about your dad and do you
feel like this doc kind of
uh proved otherwise i think this movie's
uh really it really shows you
a glimpse into hollywood the way it was
for you know since the golden age of
hollywood i think hollywood in the last
15 years has changed a lot
[Music]
and um you know there aren't movie stars
in quotes like there were back then
right and um you know
it was it was a lot different back then
and um
you know we the media was
a lot different yeah i think actors of
his generation
everybody like that time like the
beginning of the internet
and like the height of the paparazzi in
the 90s and 2000s
was a really wild and really brutal time
in the media
and i think it's a time like i think
audiences like
right now are very eager to see
kind of behind the scenes of that medium
machine and to re-evaluate things like
i keep mentioning this but like i i've
been so into like
watching what's going on with britney
spears right just we're all kind of
culturally reckoning with like
what was good well what just happened
like how the media treated these people
yeah so i think that that's like
something i mean my dad
also has a reputation that he has
because he is a very serious very
dedicated
actor theater actor so he comes across
as very serious but he's actually very
funny and i think he's a lot
he's a lot like britney spears you know
in any way
how so jack how so
crazy yeah the dancing the
the style a unique sense of humor that's
also kind of the theme of the movie is
like
how um like through art
you really can grapple with the most
difficult parts of life and like
a lot of grief in his life and he's had
a lot of hardships with his illness and
things but he's always like
even he'd be in the hospital filming
everything and making collages and
everything and
and the film is really about yeah i mean
yeah just and just like the behind the
scenes footage is amazing and the
like the good you know the goofing off
at
top gun level is like it's just so
fun to watch that was so cool i had
never seen the behind the scenes of the
top gun
it's almost like he brought that energy
to every project he's worked on because
that's just who he is like he's so
dedicated to his craft but he also
knows how to you know have a good time
yeah sometimes you know against his
better judgment
yeah but it but it keeps the captain
insane you know for sure
what do you guys hope your dad's legacy
will be
what i'm like very proud of about our
dad is that
he's very like dedicated intellectual
actor thespian a classically trained
actor
but he's also has a very kind of
populist
mentality that he's always really had a
lot of reverence for
big hollywood pictures you know and i
think he's
he's been able to do something that not
many people have which is to bring like
that level of craft into
this kind of big comic book attitude you
know like
big hollywood movies and because he's
always really loved like
the enter entertainment of for like the
people like
you know he i think he could have had a
more academic like elitist
career but that's something that i i
think is
uh his legacy is that he
has been able to kind of integrate
a lot of what is great about american
film entertainment and theater i think
he's just like a
combination of like just marlon brando
britney spears and
jimi hendrix too wow yeah
that's kind of amazing i see myself as a
sensitive
intelligent human being but with the
soul of a clown